a new anti-woke Hero has surfaced for
many on the anti-trans right his name is
Senator Matt McKee he is a state senator
in Arkansas he did the heroic thing
where he asked a trans pharmacist
whether she has a penis and this makes
you a hero among much of the anti-trans
right let me set this up for you uh
before we play the clip and the clip is
quite stunning Arkansas has been on this
Warpath to do things that really aren't
worth doing in order to Virtue signal
like for example Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders signing a law Banning
critical race Theory being taught in
public schools which of course it's not
being taught in public schools so it
doesn't really matter okay Arkansas also
is on this path to criminalize gender
affirming Care Medical Care we're
talking about and this is part of the
battle against trans people and there
was an almost surreal moment
during which Republican state senator
Matt McKee asked a trans pharmacist
Gwendolyn Herzig whether she has a penis
now the bill that was being discussed
eventually passed on Monday morning with
only one Democrat at the meeting voting
against it this is Senate Bill 199 to
open up doctors who provide gender
affirming care to youth
significant uh loopholes and additional
malpractice liabilities and all sorts of
different things in order to make it
more difficult to provide that care and
so a pharmacist named Wendell and Herzig
who is a trans-arkansas
spoke against the bill spoke against SB
199 shared her experience as a trans
person and health care provider in the
state of Arkansas she did not receive
much respect but she was asked do you
have a penis take a listen to this you
said that you're a trans woman I trans
female yes sir do you have a penis
that's horrible you're the one you're
the one that brought that into the
discussion yeah really on the Vanguard
of political philosophy and medical
treatment as you can see here do you
have a penis I would turn it around on
this guy and say sir I know you're a
dick but do you have a penis
um the obsession with other people's
genitalia
is really something the anti-trans
people consider that heroic they think
that's a massive anti-woke Victory to
really ask the questions that need
asking it's biology and Truth or
whatever it is right globalist
International yeah you know this stuff I
hate to say it folks I really do
I would get out of Arkansas and the
reason I hate to say it is most people
can't just easily move to another state
that it's just a reality either for
financial reasons because you're
established in a certain State your
job's not mobile your family is not
mobile everyone you know is in a
particular place so you know my instinct
is always to say
work within the system and figure out
how to improve things and Lobby and all
these different things Arkansas is
becoming so backwards we've looked at
the health care numbers near the bottom
we've looked at the crime numbers near
the worst in the country we've looked at
the education numbers we've looked at
the infrastructure numbers Arkansas is
not a great place to be and I'm sure
Little Rock has beautiful cafes and you
can get a great cappuccino and maybe
even a bagel but
um it it's really going in a bad
Direction now under the stewardship if
you can call it that of Sarah Huckabee
Sanders wasting resources and money and
time on meaningless things the openly
anti-trans attacks that are going on I
don't know at this point that it's the
sort of thing where listen if you don't
if if you don't have
if you're in the position to say I can
deal with a horrible place for 10 years
because I want to make it better through
activism I'm with you I'm with you but
for so many people at this point
it has become so disastrous in that
state
that it may be time to leave and that's
a really difficult thing to do in a lot
of different ways but it has gotten
disastrously bad in Arkansas do you have
a penis the latest in the battle lines
against the wokesters or whatever it is
they call it they see this as a victory
we see it as humiliating one of our
sponsors today is fume fume is on a
mission to accelerate Humanity's breakup
from the bad habits that consume far too
many of us including ones that harm our
health fume is a natural diffusive
device that uses plants and Behavioral
Science to trade out your negative habit
for a positive one fume is not a vape
it's a non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
fume's new version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap that's fun to
fidget with its fume's goal to make
switching easy or even enjoyable they
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below